ええええええ
tee
[音楽]
adele
今日このセッションのテーマウェイディスカバリー
ず田ということで最後に皆さんと宇宙の話をしたいと思います
僕は今小型衛星を使ったし宇宙探査というものをしていませ
この小型衛星トナー人より小さいサイズ中には手のひらサイズなものもありません
性能という面では大型衛星に後るんですけれども
低コストかつ短期間で開発できるというメリットを持っています
また c 宇宙というのは深い宇宙と改定
see you 中といいますでこれ定義は人によってまちまちなんですけれども僕達
小型衛星界隈では地球の周辺から離れた外のことをしいう中って言ってますのでこの
定義に沿うと月っていうのは
c 宇宙なります
で僕は今この小型衛星が宇宙空間で自由に動き回るための園児の研究をしています
でこれがそのエンジンの写真の一部になります
で左側が燃料を流したり止めたりするための蛇口のようなパーツで遊び右側が蛇口な
パーツで左側が燃料を宇宙空間に吐き出すためのパーツになります見て分かる通り非常
に小さなパーツでこの小型エンジンというのは構成されています
デコ型特有い上に特有の物理現象も多くあって研究として面白い反面
開発としての難しさもあります
僕が宇宙工学やりたいって初めて認識したのは中学生の時
将来的に何をやりたいか書きなさいというプリントが配られた時でした
でこの時初めて中学生なりに僕は将来何をやりたいんだろうなってちょっとまじめに
考えました
でその時パって思い込んできたのが宇宙工学でした
これたぶん ufo とか宇宙人とか大好きな
それを彼がオカルトの話が大好きな僕の父親の影響もあったと思います
その時は宇宙工学で具体的にこういうことをしたいなーっていうようなことは思った来
てなんとなく宇宙工学てこのそうだなぁデザイナー
そういう気持ちでした
中学高校で音信であって東大に導かれ
航空宇宙工学科に進学しました
学部時代は僕フットサル貼ったりしてたんですけれども4年生の時に今いる研究室に
配属され
素晴らしい研究者学生に出会い小型衛星による
c 宇宙探査に魅了されました
大学院に進んだ修士1年生の時
東大と jaxa が共同開発したプロピオン
と呼ばれる小型衛星の開発運用に携わりました
この写真宇宙に行く直前のプロ今日の写真になります
このプロピオン世界初の超小型 c 宇宙探査機として50センチ症というすごく
小さな体で地球から遥か遠くにある小惑星を目指して宇宙を旅しました
皆さんにとって身近な衛星というと気象衛星のひまわりっていうものがあります
でこのひまわり最大で大きさ約8m になります
この50センチ症というのがいいかに小さいから別れたと思います
この写真プロぴょんが一度し宇宙から地球に近づいてくる時に
プロピオンから地球を撮影した写真になります
最初は距離が遠くて地球も小さく写っていたんですけれども
右方向に行くに据えてだんだんプロピオンと地球が近くなってくるに据えて撮影される
地球の映像も大きくなっていきました
この写真を見て僕たちの作ったもの作ったプロピオンが実際に宇宙を飛んでいるんだ
なあっていうのを改めて実感することができました
エンジントラブル等があって全てのミッションを成功させることができなかったんです
けれども
小型衛星による4宇宙探査という新たな世界を切り開きました
今現在はまた別のエクレウスという小さな
深宇宙探査機の開発に関わっています
近衛9レースプロキオンよりもさらに小さくて大きさは10センチかける
20センチかける30センチも重さにして約14kg
人一人で簡単に持ち上げられてしまうようなそんなすごく小さな衛星です
でこのエクレウスへ2年後の2019年に nasa が開発する新型のロケット
sns というロケットで宇宙に打ち上げられ地球と月の間にある
ラグランジュ点と呼ばれるポイントを目指して家をたりします
このラグランジュ点っていうのはざっくり言うと地球と月の間にある
すごく安定した場所です
でこの場所は将来的に宇宙基地の建設場所や宇宙旅行のターミナルとして期待が高まっ
ている
そんな場所です
で僕は今このエクレースに搭載する水を燃料とした小型演じ
水エンジンの開発に関わっています
実際にこのエクレウスの中に約1リットルの水が積まれていてそれを燃料として
ラグランジェ展 see you 中に飛び立って行きます
こんな感じで僕は今小型衛星だったり v 型エンジンの研究開発に関わっています
傍から見たら宇宙ってなんか夢があってワクワクしたことやってるなーって思うかも
しれません
っぽくも最初はそんなカールへ気持ち特に具体的な小屋なくて軽い気持ちでこの世界に
足を踏み入れました
で代役の航空宇宙学科に行くと僕よりももっと宇宙が好きな人
もっと宇宙に詳しい人がたくさんいてでそういう人と宇宙の話をして実際に精開発をし
たりして
今本当に毎日が楽しいです
でもその反面くらい現実っていうのもあります
皆さんこの30%という数字なんだと思いますか
これ東大で航空宇宙工学を学んだ学生のうち航空宇宙業界に進む人の割合です
傍から見たら宇宙っていうすごく楽しそうなことをやっているのに実はそのまま航空
宇宙業界住む人ってそんなに多くありません
もちろん航空宇宙業界より他の業界にもそれぞれ魅力
価値があるのでみんながみんな航空宇宙業界に行く必要もないと思いますし
そんなことはあり得ないと思っています
ただ航空宇宙よりももっと面白いこと
もっとやりたいことがあるって言う自分の強い意志を持って自分の道を決めている
そんな人はあんまり多くないです
これって何でだと思いますか
宇宙って夢に溢れててワクワクした世界ってそういうイメージですよね
でも夢に溢れてるって裏を返せばそれが将来的に実現できるかどうか
確定的じゃないつまり将来的に不安定ぽく見える
そんな世界なんです
そんな不安定そうな世界を見て見えないはずの将来のリスクにビビって自分のやりたい
ことをあきらめて
一見安定そうに見えるすぐそこにある
規定世界
に進んでしまいます
そういう人が多いです
猫の規定世界っていうのはすでに点と点があってそれが線で結ばれていてなんとなく
大きな道筋が見えている
そんな世界です
でこのちょっと頭にきたたちはこの道筋の上で少しだけ変わったことをして自分なんか
すごいこと慕って満足しちゃってます
なんかよくわかんないけど有名な会社に行こうとか言う人がまさに典型です
そういう人たちはこの規定世界っていうのを安定しているって考えています
でもそれって間違っててきてー世界は決して安定じゃなくてむしろ宇宙業界みたいな
先の見えない見てー世界と同じぐらいの不安定性を持っています
ですーにある道3のレバー誰でも歩けるような規定世界っていうのは
競争相手がすごくいてその中で自分を出していくのはかなり大変です
しかもすでにある点と線
道筋を基にしているので持つもしそれがなくなった時に自分がどうしていいかわかん
なくなってしまいます
そういう不安定性を否定世界というのは思っています
一方で宇宙みたいな先の見えない見てー世界っていうのは
一部の点だけが見えていてそれがまだ線で繋がっていない
そんな世界です
こんな世界で自分のやりたいことをやりきっていけばだんだん店が増えていきます
それをさらに続けていけばこの点が線で結ばれていきます
ここで重要なのが皆さんが思っている以上にこの線っていうのは勝手につながっていく
ということです
どういうことかというと僕今日今この安田コードでしゃべっている姿
ちょっと前まで全く創造性していませんでした
c ここでしゃべるために何か頑張ろうなんてことは一切してません
僕はただ博士課程に住んで研究をしてそれを学会発表したり衛星開発をして
し宇宙探査をしたり
僕がやっていること宇宙利用のことをもっと他の人にも知ってもらおうと思って
youtube で学会を生配信したり
この小型エンジンの技術と宇宙利用の拡大の手段の一つとして事業化しようとしたり
自分がやりたいって思ったことをやって言ったらたまたま縁もあって今この場で喋って
います
見る人によっては博士課程に住んで研究したり
性開発したりエリートだなぁとか事業化しようとするなんて
チャレンジャーだなーとかって思うかもしれません
で僕は決してエリートでもチャレンジャーでもなくてただ純粋に自分のやりたいこと
放棄身を追い求めただけの普通の学生
挑戦しようなんて仰々しいことを意識したことは1回もありません
ただ純粋にその瞬間瞬間に自分のやりたいことをやっている
普通の学生
今見えている規定世界もまだ見えない未定世界も同じぐらいの不安定性を持っています
そんな不安定性があるんだったらもっと肩の力抜いてやりたいことをただやったら方が
良くないですか
やりたいことをやってから点と点が増えていってそれが戦で勝手につながっていきます
でそれ続けていけばこのテントこの点も繋がりそうだなんじゃのがだんだん見えてくる
ようになります
そうなったらもうこっちのもんでそれ繰り返していけば
気付いた時には新しい世界が形成されていて自分もその世界に飛び込んでいます
今僕も今日この場で喋っていろんな人の知識
考えた方に触れて次の点に線がつながる
予感しかしていません
今後宇宙開発間違いなく発展していきます
何百何千という小型衛星が地球の周りを飛び回っている
そんな世界がもうすぐそこまで来ています
エクレースのし宇宙探査結果をもとにして
ラグランジュ点地球と月の間にある安定した場所に宇宙基地が形成される日が来るかも
しれません
女性の周りを回っている星に塩セラどすという星があります
この塩すらボスの表面からは大量の水蒸気が増えていることが分かっています
今僕が開発している水エンジンがこの遠征等どすの水を燃料としてさらに遠くの宇宙や
旅する日が来るかもしれません
ブロックし間引いて地球に非常によく似た星も見つかっています
いつかこの星に人類が辿り着く日が来るかもしれません
衛星
エンジン道などほしい
そういう点を線でつないでいっていろんな人と新しい世界を想像し創造していきたいと
思っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]